THREATENING TO KILL THEM.
NONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO DID THAT
WILL FACE CONSEQUENCES FOR THEM.
MARK MARK MCCLOSKEY FACES FOUR
YEARS IN PRISON AND UP TO A
$10,000 CRIME FOR THE CRIME OF
DEFENDING HIMSELF WHEN NO ONE
ELSE WOULD.
MARK MCCLOSKEY JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
I CAN’T IMAGINE HOW YOU FEEL.
LIKE YOU HAVE WOKEN UP IN A
COUNTRY YOU DON’T RECOGNIZE.
TELL US WHERE YOU ARE RIGHT NOW
LEGALLY, IF U.N.
>> WELL, IT’S TOTALLY UPSIDE
DOWN WORLD, TUCKER.
THE PEOPLE WHO BROKE INTO MY
NEIGHBORHOOD WERE ALL
TRESPASSING.
THE GUY THAT RECRUITED IT, THEY
PLANNED THIS EVENT, SAID THE
NEXT DAY THAT HE INTENDED TO
BREAK THE LAW, THAT HE NEEDED TO
BREAK LAWS IN ORDER TO SEND HIS
MESSAGE.
NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
ARRESTED.
CHARGED.
THE PROSECUTOR, THE CIRCUIT
ATTORNEY HAS APPARENTLY DECIDED
HER JOB AS A PROSECUTOR ISN’T TO
KEEP US SAFE FROM CRIMINALS BUT
TO KEEP THE CRIMINALS SAY FROM
US.
IT’S A BIZARRE UPSIDE DOWN WORLD
WORLD.
I’VE BEEN A LITTLE IRRITATED BY
THIS PROCESS UNTIL TODAY AND NOW
I AM JUST FLAT OUT PISSED OFF.
IT’S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Tucker: YOU SHOULD BE
AFRAID TOO.
THE FORCE OF THE STATE IS COMING
DOWN ON YOU FOR THE MOST BASIC
RIGHTS THAT EXIST, THE RIGHT OF
SELF-DEFENSE.
ARE YOU GOING TO STAY IN A PLACE
THAT SEEKS TO PUT YOU IN PRISON
FOR DEFENDING YOURSELF?
>> YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY HAS TO
STAND UP AND DO WHAT’S RIGHT.
I’M NOT GOING TO BE BULLIED.
I’M NOT GOING TO BE INTIMIDATED.
THE LEFT, THE MOB USES SOCIAL
INTIMIDATION AND THREATS TO GET
PEOPLE TO KNUCKLE UNDER AND
APOLOGIZE FOR DOING WHAT’S
RIGHT.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO APOLOGIZE
FOR DOING WHAT’S RIGHT.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BACK DOWN
AND WE ARE NOT GOING TO MOVE.
PEOPLE NEED TO STAND UP, WAKE UP
AND RECOGNIZE IT FOR WHAT IT IS.
IT’S A CONCERTED EFFORT TO
DESTROY OUR WAY OF LIFE, TO
CHANGE THE FUNDAMENTAL BASIC
SOCIAL CONTRACT, TO DO AWAY WITH
CAPITALIST DEMOCRACY AND REPLACE
IT WITH MOB RULE.
ENCOURAGING VIOLENCE, PROTECTING
CRIMINALS FROM PROSECUTING
PEOPLE TO TRY TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AGAINST IT.
IT’S A BIZARRE WORLD.
IT’S TIME FOR PEOPLE TO WAKE UP
AND PAY ATTENTION TO IT.
>> Tucker: HAS ANYONE
EXPLAINED WHAT YOU WERE SUPPOSED
TO DO IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
POLICE WOULD NOT RESPOND, THEY
WOULD NOT COME TO PROTECT YOU
DESPITE THE FACT YOU PAY THEM
AND PRIVATE SECURITY WOULDN’T
COME EITHER, PROBABLY FOR FEAR
OF BEING SUED.
WHAT WERE YOU SUPPOSED TO DO
ONCE PEOPLE BREAK IN AND START
THREATENING YOU?
>> WHAT VARIOUS COMMENTATORS
HAVE SUGGESTED IS WE SHOULD HAVE
GONE INSIDE AND FILM THEM WITH
OUR CELL PHONES.
WELL, DO YOU WANT TO HAVE 300
PEOPLE INSIDE YOUR HOUSE
BREAKING STUFF, SETTING FIRES
AND KILLING YOU OR WOULD YOU
RATHER STOP THEM WHEN THEY ARE
OUTSIDE.
WE CHOSE TO STOP THEM FROM
COMING IN.
>> Tucker: WHAT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN NOW?
DO YOU HAVE A FEAR OF GOING TO
PRISON?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON’T KNOW.
I HAVE VERY LITTLE FAMILIARITY
WITH CRIMINAL PROCESS.
WE HAVE GOTTEN SUPPORT NOW FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE ON DOWN.
GOVERNOR PARSON, THE SENATOR,
ERIC SCHMIDT, OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE ONLY PERSON IN
THE UNITED STATES THE THINGS WE
DID SOMETHING WRONG IS OUR
SURROGATE ATTORNEY.
SHE IS THE SAME PERSON THAT LET
OUT OF JAIL EVERYBODY THAT WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE LOOTING AND
FIRES AND DESTRUCTION FOLLOWING
THE GEORGE FLOYD DEATH IN THE
CITY OF ST. LOUIS.
THE ONLY PEOPLE SHE WANTS TO
PROSECUTE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
DEFENDED THEMSELVES AGAINST IT
AND NOBODY ELSE TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU BETTER
TARGET OF CRIME.
YOU HAVEN’T BACKED DOWN.
YOU’VE GONE ON TELEVISION
REPEATEDLY.
PEOPLE KNOW WHERE YOU LIVE.
AND THE STATE HAS NOW
CONFISCATED YOUR FIREARMS SO YOU
CAN PROTECT YOURSELF.
ON WHAT GROUNDS DID THEY DO
THAT?
THOSE WERE LEGALLY REGISTERED AS
FAR AS I UNDERSTAND.
>> I GUESS THE TECHNICALITY OF
THE LAW IS THEY HAVE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
WEAPONS WERE CAPABLE OF BEING
FATAL OR CAUSING SERIOUS BODILY
HARM.
SO THEY HAVE TO TAKE THEM AND
TEST THEM AND THAT SORT OF
THING.
THERE WILL BE SOME REVELATIONS
TO COME OUT ABOUT THAT BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THE POLICE,
I’VE SAID THIS BEFORE, THE
POLICE WHO CAME OUT TO ISSUE THE
WARRANT DIDN’T WANT TO HAVE TO
DO IT.
THEY KNEW THEY WERE JUST DOING
THEIR JOB.
THEY WERE VERY POLITE ABOUT IT
BUT NONETHELESS, YOU’RE RIGHT.
THEY PRESENT THE MOB AND THEN
STRIP US OF OUR ABILITY TO
DEFEND AGAINST IT.
>> Tucker: IT’S ALMOST
UNBELIEVABLE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMING ON
TONIGHT.